and this next award is going out to our
own little pam beasley i think we all
know what award pam is gonna be getting
this year
it is the whitest sneakers award because
she always has the whitest tennis shoes
on
[Applause]
[Music]
okay first off my kids
because i couldn't have done it without
them
thank you
let's give michael a round of applause
for emceeing tonight because
this is a lot harder than it looks
and also because of dwight too um
so
finally i want to thank god
because god gave me this dundee
and i feel god in this chili's tonight
thank you
[Laughter]
what a great year for the dundees we got
to see ping
and we learned michael's true feelings
for ryan which was touching
and we
heard michael changed the lyrics to a
number of classic songs
which for me
has ruined them for life
what
nothing
okay
what
i don't know what
oh my god
you are
so drunk
did you get that please tell me that you
got this is all going to be hard woman
grab your tongue it's okay i'm a
sheriff's deputy well he's a volunteer
don't get into that now we need
something to cushion our head throw
pillow a cushion dwight okay i'm gonna
use my shirt
i'm sorry sir you're gonna have to put
your clothes
you